[Music]
hey you guys
book review time once again this is my
tomes of terror show
now this is a book that i just kind of
like picked up sort of randomly
here's an interesting story behind this
and i'll tell you in a second but this
book
came out in 1999 and this is called
others
by james herbert now i had actually
heard of james herbert he's a
quite a famous writer was a famous
writer i should say because he died in
2013 i believe
i actually first heard of him through
stephen king
stephen king mentioned him in his book
dance macabre i think he mentioned a
couple of his
better known novels uh the rats which i
think it was his first one
and the fog the fog by james herbert
herbert the book
it doesn't have anything to do with the
john carpenter movie it's a completely
different story
i think it's kind of like a um you know
like a chemical spill type of thing that
makes everybody
go crazy or like commit suicide or
whatever i think those are kind of his
best-known books but he wrote a shit-ton
of them
and he's kind of known as britain's
stephen king
so take of that which you will and i'm
not going to say the style is similar
because it's not really but
james herbert as is actually like a
really really well known
i mean his stuff has been translated
into like 30 something languages
and he's sold like millions and millions
of books all over the world so
even though maybe in the u.s his name
isn't as
uh recognizable as stephen king i mean
you know what writer's name is as
recognizable as stephen king
but you know around the world he is
pretty much
in the same tier like in the same league
and he writes kind of the same
kind of stuff popular fiction like
popular horror fiction popular sci-fi
fiction but i don't mean that
as uh to denigrate it in any way because
um i can actually
see this is actually the first james
herbert that i had read
it's interesting because like i said i
knew the name i had heard of him before
uh i had heard of his first two novels i
think
even nowadays i think those are probably
his best-known ones
but i was in a second-hand bookstore uh
in saint augustine and i just happened
to see this book like sitting up a thing
i was like oh james herbert i don't
think i've read any of his stuff and i
had heard his name and it's like i
should probably rectify that
and i had never heard of this book and i
wasn't aware that it was
as recent as it was i thought it was
older for some reason i thought it was
like 70s and 80s paperback but it's not
it's from 1999.
so i decided to pick it up and as usual
i just kind of went by the name
and i said i'm not even going to read
the synopsis on the back i don't want to
know what this is about
i'm just going to like let it wash over
me i just i don't know i like to do that
i used to read the backs on stuff
and i still do if i don't know who the
author is
but if i recognize the author's name or
somebody has recommended the book to me
then i usually like to go into it
completely blind
and i'm glad i did on this one because i
had no idea what this was about
and so i didn't really know where it was
going and i ended up really really
getting into this book i mean i really
got into this [ __ ]
it's just like it was it was crazy how
much i got into this i think
the reason that i got into it so much
and i've heard that
other that james herbert's other books
are kind of the same
was that the protagonist of this it's
all from it's all like uh first person
the protagonist of this is such a great
character he's just like so complex it's
like you really get inside his head he's
like i really felt
like he was a real person like talking
to me and stuff like that which you
don't always get because sometimes you
know the character work is
in some novels is not you know even if
the plot is cool and everything like
that
but this one i really really got into
this dude and i was just kind of like he
was so
he was such a fascinating person um and
all this stuff that was happening was
just like so [ __ ] crazy
that i really really got into it and i
read this one like really really quickly
because i just kept like picking it up
and being like now what happened that
would happen
so it's so that's what i mean by um him
being like the stephen king or like you
know being
way up there in like popular fiction um
i can see how
people that aren't even really that into
horror although this one is kind of has
some pretty grotesque
[ __ ] in it um but even people that
aren't really that into horror
you know as a general like aren't like
horror dorks like i am
i would totally enjoy this also although
like i said this one does have some
pretty grotesque uh [ __ ] in it
so if you're not into that and you know
it is kind of like upsetting
you know some of the imagery and it is
kind of upsetting so
if you think that's going to bother you
then no but i but other than that i can
see how
uh you know a lot of people would be
into this so the story
behind this this is really interesting
because i wasn't like i said i didn't
know anything about where this book was
going
the very first chapter the very first
section of it's almost got a little
like a little bit of a prologue and
you figure out pretty quickly that this
prologue
takes place in hell so
not like flames and everything like that
but sort of like
you know a dante sort of hell or
something like that where there's just
kind of these
anguished souls and they're just in
these they're disembodied and they're in
these cells
it's like they kind of remember their
lives and everything but there's no
there's nothing around them like you
know no landscapes and everything's just
like
dark so we have the main protagonist who
i believe it the first is not
named and two angels
come to him this is really funny because
if you're thinking that this is gonna go
a certain way because i'm like sitting
there looking
like is this like a fantasy novel like i
wasn't really sure but then it kind of
goes like in a more normal direction so
you know but it all comes back to it in
the end it's really kind of hard to
describe so these two angels come to him
and basically they're like
well every 500 years or so we pick
a handful of damned souls that are in
hell
and we give you another go-around like
you can go back to earth and try to
redeem yourself
um you know in another body in the
modern age
so this particular damned soul that
they're talking to who ends up being the
protagonist of the book
uh was one of these lucky people now you
learned you don't learn a lot about
what he was like before he went to hell
basically all he's all they say about
him is that
he was uh a quite a famous movie star
like back in the 30s and 40s
and that he was kind of a [ __ ] like um
you know he
abandoned his kitty blackmail people so
he was just kind of like a shitty human
being
but for whatever reason they've decided
that he's one of the ones that they're
gonna pick this time around
to go back to earth and try to redeem
himself
now the only caveat to that being he's
not gonna remember
like when he's born into his new body
he's not gonna remember
any of this so he's so it's not gonna be
like he can go around on purpose and
being like oh man i gotta do like some
good [ __ ] so i can like go to heaven
this time
he he's not gonna remember anything
about his former life he's not gonna
remember anything like that
and also um i don't really think they
tell him this
but they basically say you know it's
gonna be like
really super hard and everything like
that and you don't really find out what
they mean
until you figure until we jump ahead to
uh the modern day or like i said the
contemporaneous one
when this book was written which was
1999. so
after that you know you're led to
believe that now this soul is going back
to earth and then
the significant portion the book other
than the very very very end
is him as a in a different body
and not really remembering his former
life
although there are kind of like echoes
of it which i'll kind of get into in a
bit
jump ahead to 1999 and we're in
brighton england and we're following
a private investigator named nick
dismiss and nick dismiss is
i guess he's in his like 30s or 40s so
he's like lived kind of a
kind of a shitty life up to up to now
now nick
is profoundly disfigured
what ended up happening was that when he
was born
he was so disabled in the fact that i
mean his
he's very very intelligent and
everything like that but he's
kind of funny looking like some people
like call him like quasimodo and stuff
like that because he has like a humped
back like his spine is
uh disfigured he has one leg that
doesn't really work all that well
um you know he only has um like his head
is kind of misshapen
and he only has one eye although
that happened like later on like when he
was a kid like one of his eyes got poked
out
so he's kind of come to terms with the
fact that
he can't go anywhere without everybody
staring at him
or you know making fun of him kicking
the [ __ ] out of him stuff like that and
he's kind of lived his whole entire life
up to this point when the book starts
kind of dealing
with that it's interesting because
what i mean when i say he's such a great
character is that
even though he has all of these
disabilities
and even though he spent his entire life
i mean he was abandoned
as a baby um so we're led to assume that
the woman that gave birth to him was
just like oh hell no and like left him
in a dumpster like behind a convent or
something and he was raised by nuns
and he kind of had like a shitty
upbringing you know and
children's homes kind of got passed from
one to the other but as i said
he was very intelligent and he was just
interested in
uh detective work so he ended up
becoming an investigator
and at this point he has his own small
uh investigations firm
uh with some really good friends he has
like three people working for him
uh who are also like really good
characters they don't do a lot with them
but
you know that they're also good
characters and friends of his and he's
kind of like established a pretty nice
life for himself like he has
you know he still has some self-pity and
things like that because you know he
doesn't have a girlfriend and he thinks
he's never going to get one because of
what he looks like and um you know he
still gets
picked on on the regular you know he's
got his he gets his ass kicked like
by a bunch of girls like in a gang on
the pier
and stuff like that so it's that kind of
thing he had uh
he said he had a lot of trouble with
like drugs and stuff like that when he
was
younger but he's kind of gotten over
that now now he's just
likes to drink a lot and uh smoke weed
but that's kind of all he does now like
to sort of alleviate
oh and i think he does coke sometimes
too but uh but yeah so
he's just kind of like trying to cope
with things the best that he's can he's
a very relatable character
and he's just like his really down to
earth very intelligent
dude so we kind of established that
now what ends up happening is that this
woman
named shelly comes to him and she has
been referred to his agency
by a friend of his named etta who was a
solicitor
this woman um she said that her husband
has just died
and there's like some issue with the
will or anything and her and her husband
had never been able to have children
because i guess he was um you know he
his he was shooting blanks or whatever
and she um i guess there was some kind
of thing where the husband was
basically loved her so much that it's
like well we need to have a kid so i can
pass
my company on to the kid but i can't
give you children so go have one with
somebody else it was like it's a really
weird like uh
like thing and so it's not really here
nor there i just thought that was kind
of funny but so she's like well we never
had a kid i never had a kid with anybody
while i was married to him
she's like however two years before i
met my husband who has since passed away
i had a kid and
i had it at dartford general and i s and
she says
they told me that it died and i never
saw it
but i'm convinced that it's still alive
she knows it's a son and so
nick the investigator who everybody
calls diz
um you know because that's kind of like
his last name
so he's basically like okay well let me
get this straight
you had a baby at a just a normal
regular hospital you never saw the baby
they told you the baby died but
18 years later you're convinced that
this kid who wouldn't be a kid anymore
obviously
is still alive somewhere and she's like
yes he's like why did you come to that
conclusion she's like one i feel it
two i went to a psychic named louise and
the psychic told me
that my son was still alive somewhere
and so at this point
diz is kind of like [ __ ] me because he's
very like i said he's a really like uh
skeptical character as a lot of
investigators are so he's basically like
i don't really think i can help you it's
like you know yes it's your body
it's this is what you want to do but she
is adamant that this kid is still alive
and she's like and i have to find him
maybe not i don't know if it's not
just because she wants to but also
because it has to do with the will and
she's not gonna
you know get anything from the husband's
company or whatever
um so she's trying to find this kid so
nick is just kind of like okay fine well
it's your money i'll just
do what i can for you now he starts
looking into the matter and at first he
kind of thinks he hits a dead end
because he's like look not only is there
no record
of this kid being born there's also
there's no record of this kid dying
now it's complicated too by the fact
that the
hospital where the kid had been born had
burned down subsequently
and so all of their records were
destroyed but he's like but still
i mean the the birth and the death
should have been registered like
other than just at that hospital um you
know because
that's how it works and so he's like the
fact that there's no record of this kid
you know he goes back to them he's like
look i i just really don't think i can
help you because it's just
i've hit a dead end there's just no way
you know that that i can
go any further with this and she gets
like really upset about it and then
uh the psychic ends up coming to him and
talking about going look as this kid
it's like i heard this kid's voice um
he's still alive
he needs help and you know i know you
don't believe it and
[ __ ] like that so as the story goes on
dis starts to experience
visions now up to this point he's always
been seeing kind of like especially when
he's
inebriated or when he's on drugs or
something it's like sometimes he'll look
in the mirror
and instead of seeing you know what he
really looks like
he'll see like this really really
handsome dude who looks kind of like an
[ __ ]
now he's not aware of it at the
beginning but that's actually the dude
that he used to be
like like i said at the beginning they
sent him back in another body but he
doesn't really know that he just
knows he keeps seeing this handsome dude
like behind the mirror and he doesn't
really know who it is
but like i said he doesn't believe in
any psychic [ __ ] he doesn't believe in
reincarnation he doesn't believe in
anything like that
but he starts having visions mostly he
starts having visions of birds
and then he starts kind of like hearing
voices and all these other kind of
things
and it turns out his journey like from
skepticism to belief is also really
fascinating because he starts talking to
louise the psychic
so they kind of develop a friendship as
well and she's
trying to convince him that something
bigger is going on you know somebody's
out there they need your help and it's
you
specifically um because she's like i i
knew as soon as i saw you that you were
the person that was gonna do all this
so as it goes on he starts having these
visions of
like i said birds and all these other
things and then it turns out that
the reason he's having visions about
birds is because
shelley the woman that had the kid that
uh that nobody thinks exists
she suddenly remembers uh the midwife at
the birth because he's like look if
there's no record of it do you remember
the doctor do you remember anyone who
was there that i can you know some lead
i can take
and she remembers suddenly uh you know
there
they lead you to believe that it's kind
of like you know a psychic type of
uh flash that she has she remembers the
midwife's name it was this german woman
she said named hildegard vogel
so diz starts to investigate
where hildegard vogel went to
and in the process of tracking her down
he ends up at this elderly rest home
called perfect rest i don't know if i
want to spoil it too much from there
because there is some really shady [ __ ]
going on at this elderly home but
also he meets this other girl who works
there named constance
who has this like beautiful beautiful
face but she is also
disfigured as he is like her body is she
had i believe they said she had spina
bifida
so she has she walks with uh crutches
and everything like that and they kind
of like develop a romance too but then
he gets kind of like deeper and deeper
into
this horrific [ __ ] that's going on
at this old folks home the doctor that
runs it
and it also ties in with shelly and the
baby that she thinks doesn't exist
and it also ties in with diz and his own
uh
his disability and things like that too
so it's this whole kind of thing coming
together
and like i said it's it's dis coming to
terms with the fact that
it's almost kind of like him coming
coming from skepticism to belief
but also him redeeming himself
as i said because he was in hell prior
and uh him
having to redeem himself because for
being such a [ __ ] like in his
former life and so it's that whole kind
of thing so
this this book i don't know it's just
there was really really something about
it that was just really compelling and i
think that it was
all down to the main character and as i
said the whole thing is in first person
so everything's from his point of view
you know his thoughts you know all the
stuff that's going on and he's just such
he's such a great character he's so
complex he's so
sympathetic but not in a way that's kind
of like oh you know
he's just like he seemed so much like a
real person to me he seemed like really
really vivid
and i think that really kind of helps
you like you know helps the narrative
like go along too because
as [ __ ] gets crazier and crazier he
starts having the like crazier and
crazier visions
he starts thinking that maybe this
psychic louise is like on to something
and he's part of something bigger that
he needs to get involved in
and it's just such a great it just kind
of carries you along
and i even liked i read some
a few other reviews of this most of
which were actually really positive
a few people didn't like it because they
thought the first part like the build up
was too slow which i didn't really find
that at all
yes the first part of the book is mostly
like
an investigation like him going around
to different people and saying hey do
you know what happened to this woman and
like where this woman went and then him
trying to like get information from
various people
but i don't know i like that kind of
thing um you know i like sort of
detective stories
and that's kind of what the first half
of this is with like little bits of
supernatural
[ __ ] sprinkled through there and then it
goes kind of full on supernatural toward
the end like with psychic powers and
and stuff like that so i don't know i
just really liked the juxtaposition of
that and i thought that like the
the slow build-up of it like worked
really well because it really helped you
get into this character's head and you
know his
establish his relationships with his
friends and with other people in the
books that it made you kind of like care
about them so i don't know your mileage
may vary
if you like detective stories with
supernatural
uh aspects to it then you will probably
really really dig this i mean i really
dug it
like i said it has some very grotesque
imagery so flirting with like clive
barker type [ __ ]
uh so if you don't like that then you
know maybe give it a pass
but i mean other than that i just really
really liked it i liked it a lot and
like i said this is the first james
herbert uh that i read even though i had
heard of him
so definitely won't be the last because
this
i can see why people compare him to
stephen king even though their styles
are not
all that similar it's just the same kind
of character-driven narrative that kind
of goes from
grounded and realistic and then it just
ramps up you know the supernatural and
ramps up the craziness until and it's
good because you know it makes it more
believable as it goes along because it
just does it in like little ratcheting
steps you know what i mean so it doesn't
just go full-on psychic powers or
whatever like it like builds up to that
and like i said for a long time it's
like just
a detective it's a straight-up detective
story just with him having occasional
visions and having occasional calls from
the psychic and things like that
so if that sounds like something that
you would be into
then check it out like i said it came
out in 1999 and i had never heard of it
until i just saw it sitting on a shelf
in uh in a secondhand bookstore so uh
yeah called
others by james herbert so check it out
and that will do it for this tomes of
terror and i will see you guys on the
next one
bye